Here we have a little block
that sits on that surface.
And well, what can
one do with a block?
You can push it,
or you can pull it.
And that's exactly what
we're going to look at now.
So I can exert a pushing force
onto this block here, F push.
But I could also pull
it like this, F pull.
And the question is, how can
we formalize this a little bit
more?
We can now also look at a small
piece of rope or a string.
And I could, in the tug of
war, I'm going to pull here.
And I'm also going to pull here.
And we'll see who
is going to win.
So we have two opposing
forces here on either side.
In a slightly
different scenario,
where we're going to put both
of these things together,
we have a block here
sitting on a surface.
And we have a little
string attached to it.
And let's say we
have a pulley here,
and the string goes
around there and has
a little mass hanging here.
We want to now describe
what this force is here
that's pulling things.
And for that, we have
to look at what's
going on in that little string.
So let's draw another string.
And this is our string.
And let's take an imaginary cut
right through the middle here.
And I'm going to draw
both pieces here.
This is the left part, and
here is the right part.
And what's happening
in this rope here now?
Well, there is a force
acting on the left object
due to the interaction
with the right one.
And here we have a
force on the right one,
due to the interaction
of the left piece.
And that, of course,
happens anywhere.
I take a cut here
along the line.
And we can even formalize
that a little bit more
by just placing our
coordinate system here.
And let's say x equals 0 here.
And so for all x
along this line,
we always have these
pairs of forces.
So they are an interaction pair.
And if I look at the rope from
afar, they will cancel out.
But if I look at what's
going on inside the rope,
then this is what they are.
And we know from
Newton's third law
that F RL equals minus F LR.
So they're forces of
the same magnitude,
but the opposite direction.
If they weren't the same, then
my rope would get in trouble.
But what we want to
define now actually
is tension, the
tension force, that
is along, that's
happening along,
this rope here in our
tug of war if someone
pulls from the outside.
And for that, we
first got to look
at the magnitude of our
interaction pair here, F RL.
And that, of course, equals
the magnitude of F LR.
And we're actually going to
define now this magnitude here
as the tension force.
And that is true for
all x along this line
here, that we have
this, the magnitude,
that this is the magnitude
of this force here.
And from now on,
we're going to call--
when we talk about
tension in the rope,
then we talk about the magnitude
of one of these internal forces
here.